[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es ein leckeres
grillrezepte ich habe mir gedacht das
wetter ist schön wir schmeißen den grill
an und machen heute puppenspiel mit
gemüse zuerst werde ich jetzt mal das
fleisch marinieren das könnt ihr im
wunderbar vorbereiten gerne auch am
abend vorher oder einfach eine stunde
vorher das reicht vollkommen aus
ich mache so eine welt wird schon sagen
eine asiatische marinade ich glaube das
wird ziemlich lecker dafür nämlich 70
gramm und sojasauce 70 gramm
sonnenblumenöl drei teelöffel sesam 3
knoblauchzehen okay das bisschen
türkisch etwas pfeffer und salz und 1,3
kilo putenfleisch ok asiatisch türkisch
mein türkisch werden 15 knoblauch das
ist fakt weißt du was ich vergessen habe
plötzlich wird noch eine leichte süße
reinbringen
wir nehmen noch das was ich da ab
ach und sirup wenn ihr noch zwei
esslöffel aachen sirup oder honig oder
wasser so da hab ich nehme doch bisschen
honig jetzt ist es asiatisch so wissen
sie es muss schon sein dass fleisch habe
ich übrigens schon in würfel geschnitten
in so etwa drei bis vier zentimeter
große einfach nur darauf achten dass er
ungefähr gleichmäßig sind okay jetzt
gebt ihr alle zutaten im prinzip nur
noch eben eine schüssel die sojasauce
die sorgt halt wirklich für die würze
also wird doch schon lecker 90 gleich ob
es hat so eine aus graz krankheit muss
alles raus kurzen videos ganz sesamöl
mit rein
die knoblauchzehen die braucht ihr nicht
fehlen wenn ihr eine knoblauchpresse
habt aber wenig sie für ein reit oder
hakt müsste es natürlich stellen ich
habe gern allein 3 knoblauchzehen
gegessen so ganz allein so hatte man
erst mal dem länger und so ungefähr 2
ist noch viel süßes okay so wartet das
dauert zu lange das stellen auf dem kopf
so nach honig rhein fest geworden
okay das reicht da gibt es übrigens in
tipp des in warmes wasser zu stellen und
dann jetzt noch salz pfeffer und dann
war's das auch schon
[Musik]
hier noch den rest sehr schwäbisch und
jetzt gibt hier einfach das fleisch
rhein kann das entweder kneten oder
verrühren
[Musik]
und jetzt deckt ihr das fleisch entweder
ab und es kommt den kühlschrank und
dafür etwa mindestens eine stunde bis
ein tag marinieren
ich mache jetzt aber so weil wir nämlich
gleich essen wollen werde ich zwar
kopieren so kommen nämlich die aromen
wirklich direkt ins fleisch rein und ich
muss gar nicht so lange warten und
außerdem habe ich dann das fleisch in
einem beutel drin hab es schön luftdicht
verpackt kann es im kühlschrank lagern
oder auch zu meinen freunden zum
beispiel mitnehmen und hab es einfach
und sicher darin das ist wunderbar
ihr könnt übrigens wenn ihr so eine
große schüssel habt guckt mal den großen
teller nehmen drauflegen und dann ist es
auch wurden da war abgedeckt und ihr
könnt sogar die schüsseln stapeln also
nur mal so als live act jetzt gebe ich
hier das fleisch aber weil ich selber
kopieren möchte in meinen vakuumbeutel
und dann habt ihr wirklich innerhalb von
sekunden das komplette aroma im fleisch
drin und müsst nicht ewig warten
ich mag einen großen löffel nehmen
unschön aus grab oder oft meine platten
witze wirklich witzig finde heute was
meint jeder lacht ja auch nur aus
anstand mit oder weil er mich lustig
findet und ganz wichtig jetzt mal um
wieder zum ernsten zurückgekommen wenn
ihr geflügel schneidet ist wirklich
super wichtig dass ihr eure werkzeuge
danach gründlich reinigt ja also jetzt
nicht auf dem gleichen schneidebrett
gemüse und salat zu schneiden sondern
wirklich gründlich reinigen und jawohl
ich nur sagen
[Musik]
was ihr hier gerade blumen seht das ist
der unter druck der entsteht und so
zieht wirklich die marinade sofort ins
fleisch ein
guckt mal perfekt einmal mehr
jetzt kann ich das fleisch kurz in den
kühlschrank stellen und mich ums gemüse
kümmern denn das werden nicht nur guten
späße sondern guten gegen böse stiefel
das fleisch ist mariniert jetzt kommt
hier noch das gemüse ins spiel
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach noch
champignons dazu zucchini
cocktailtomaten rote zwiebeln und weiße
zwiebel und ich habe ich einfach nochmal
die marinade gemacht die ich eben auch
fürs fleisch gemacht habe die zwiebel
die werde ich jetzt einfach nur vierte
die dürfen gerne so groß bleiben da
könnt ihr im prinzip nehmen was euch
schmeckt ja also ich hab jetzt einfach
mal so eine schöne bunte mischung
gemacht ich finde auch so kleine jetzt
wirklich süß war dann könnt ihr die im
ganzen drauf stecken
wer dazu kini einfach das anfangs stück
und das endstück weg und je nach
durchmesser reicht wenn ihr sie einfach
in große stücke schneidet oder müsste
eben doch noch halbieren ich glaube ich
jetzt schon noch halbieren sollte doch
richtig sind dann aber ein breite stücke
schneiden im prinzip einfach ist alles
ungefähr gleich ausschneiden
[Musik]
champignons sind auch ziemlich ungleich
also die kleinen hier die last jetzt im
ganzen und die großen die halte ich
jetzt einfach nur da muss ich schon
sagen dass ich ins netz oder große
fleischesser bin deswegen gibt es bei
mir beim grillen immer ganz viel gemüse
entweder in form von salaten oder in
form von gemüsepfanne oder eben wie so
was haben wir noch die paprika und die
schneider scheint einen boden lag und
die vier saiten und dann habt ihr auch
schon so eine schöne fläche
[Musik]
ich bin noch kurz betonen dass frau ich
verschwende nichts wirklich nichts
verschwendet denn das können dann noch
es locken
ich hab's doch wahnsinn quadratisch
abgeschnitten an der quadratischen
paprika aber die dinge die mich nur noch
weg essen nämlich dem ihr versprechen
jetzt braucht ihr spieße ich probier's
mal die hieraus denn die haben so einen
schieber vielleicht klappt's ja ganz gut
ok und jetzt im prinzip einfach nur auf
spießen
ich habe es ganz gerne wenn sie
gleichmäßig aufgespießt sind alle das
heißt überall so das gleiche drauf
abwechselnd mal fleisch mal gemüse ja
das sieht doch gut aus
die tomate speichern da glaube ich bis
zum schluss auf zwiebel muss unbedingt
mit ochs am spieß
ich mache jetzt einfach so immer ein
stück fleisch ein stück gemüse und dann
finde ich reicht auch so ein spiel für
eine frau wie mich und 3 für mich passt
es dann für dich
mit bei lager natürlich also das dann
sind zwei auch okay ich finde es muss
nicht immer so viel fleisch sein beim
grillen oder auch mal gar keins als ihr
könnt doch man nur die gemüsespieße
machen mit der marinade das ist auch
okay aber ich liebe zucchini zucchini
und 2 ja das sieht doch ich glaube
bisschen mehr rot wäre schön gewesen
aber da kommt jetzt gleich tomate 1234
so legen wir das jetzt hier ab und jetzt
versuche ich alle eigentlich schließe
exakt so zu machen
ich glaube ich mir das so dass mir
vorher
[Musik]
so sehen die spieße jetzt aus und ich
gebe jetzt hier einfach noch über das
gemüse so ein bisschen die marinade
drüber
und die können dann im prinzip schon
direkt auf den grill ich werde jetzt
noch ein paar veganer spießer machen für
unsere veganer hier im haus das ich eben
ein bisschen marinade auf und spieß
einfach nur gemüse auf ohne fleisch und
dann sehen wir uns gleich draußen und am
grill ich muss echt sagen ich bin so
schlecht im grillfeuer machen aber ich
glaube da muss ich mich selber also
youtube tutorials angucken gut der
kritische auch nicht da wo ich meinen
grillen ganz ehrlich das feuer bisschen
kohle und feiere ich finde feuer machen
das müssen die männer wie frauen
bereiten chance erstens so und die
männer und die morgens früher und heute
morath nicht da ist weiß ich wer das
heute machst du bist du aus erwähnte ach
schön und guck mal ich hab ganz wenig
gemüse nur übrig als es ging echt fast
komplett auf und wenn ich jetzt nicht
nur an die veganer denken wird für dich
einfach so ein gemüsespieße und rest des
spiels machen hat man immer das was
nicht aufgeht und ja noch ganz
gemüsespieße und dann wieder am grill an
dem wunderbaren feuer
von j
das kann ich die spieße grill und da
einfach aufpassen da ist wirklich
geflügel gut durchgegart verzerrt wird
unter mehrmaligen wenn jetzt einfach
schön durchgang ich mache es dann oft so
dass ich einfach beim ersten spiels mal
kurz durch probieren und schauen und
dann könnte da auch gewissheit haben
dass sie wirklich schön durch sind
[Musik]
so eine botschaft an meine zuschauer und
die schrecklich ernst zu nehmen könnt
ihr bitte in die kommentare schreiben
dass mein mann mehrmals gescheiten
geholt ich mache so leckeres essen ich
bereit alles so toll vor
und dann habe ich einfach so einen grill
auf dem ich nicht wirklich gewinnen kann
ich hätte gerne glauben eckigen grill
und dann einfach ein wo ich spiele und
alles mögliche alleine schön grillen
kann muss vorher machen nicht so schwer
ist und einfach der mein essen der
meinem essen würdig ist bitte schreibt
freien ok danke dann mache ich noch mehr
leckere grillrezepte also hier seht ihr
diese öffnungen ja die war bis vor
kurzem nicht da da kam mein papa und wir
haben öfter gegrillt und kaufte ich hab
da so nur ihr kennt doch diesen grill
aufsatz dafür fisch zum beispiel oder
geben oder für späße naja egal
jedenfalls hat der grill aufsatz kann
ich so drauf gepasst und man habe ein
paar was ich gedacht und flex ich das
hier einfach weg und hat mir noch in
meiner kugelgrill rein geflext der zum
glück schon uralt ist aber ich hab
nichts sagt weil ich wollte papa einfach
da hat sehr gut gemeint und dann habe
ich gesagt super basis gemacht die
verkehre supereinfach und da hat sich
gefreut nur wenn man jetzt neuen grill
holen dann sollte er das vielleicht
nicht machen weil dann wäre es
vielleicht wissen schade
[Musik]
guck mal die spitze sehen nach dem grill
wunderbar aus und ich probierte es jetzt
mal aus an einem ich habe selbst ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen
normalerweise muss man halt grillen
einfach grill und dann direkt auf dem
tisch und sofort essen aber ihr wisst
wir fotografieren dann immer noch alles
ich probiere das jetzt mal ich bin
begeistert er ist klappt und dann kann
man das schön essen am besten noch ein
paar grill beilagen dazu machen dazu
habe ich auch schon ein video gemacht
ich habe sowieso allgemein schon einige
krähen videos gemacht schaut euch gerne
die videos dazu an und dann wünsche ich
euch einen guten appetit
ich hoffe und bete dass ich bald einen
schöneren grill bekomme auf dem ich
wirklich gut hören kann
bitte schreibt einfach in die kommentare
okay das ist ja unsere interne abmachung
also bis zum nächsten mal und tschüss
[Musik]